>> Greg: THE WHITE GUILT NEVER
ENDS.
EVEN FOR THE CREATOR OF FRIENDS.
YEAH, SHE TURNED ON THE SITCOM
SHE BUILT TO SATISFY HER
CAUCASIAN GUILT.
THE COCREATOR OF FRIENDS SAYS
SHE'S EMBARRASSED BY THE SHOW'S
LACK OF DIVERSITY AND SHE IS
PLEDGING FOR A MILLION BUCKS TO
BRANDEIS UNIVERSITY TO SUPPORT
ITS AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDIES
DEPARTMENT.
KAUFMAN ALSO REGRETS HER
ORIGINAL NAME FOR THE SERIES
WHICH WAS "WHITE PEOPLE ARE
AWESOME."
I COULD'VE WORN HER.
THE SHOW'S STARS SIX BEST BUDS
LIVING IN APARTMENTS THEY COULD
NEVER AFFORD IN REAL LIFE.
IT BECAME A HUGE SUCCESS, PAVING
WAY FOR SUCH AMAZING SPIN-OFFS
LIKE "JOEY."
SAID KAUFMAN IN A RECENT
INTERVIEW "I LEARNED A LOT IN
THE LAST 20 YEARS.
ADMITTING AND ACCEPTING GUILT IS
NOT EASY.
IT'S PAINFUL LOOKING AT YOURSELF
IN THE MIRROR.
I'M EMBARRASSED I DIDN'T KNOW
BETTER 25 YEARS AGO."
BUT NOW THAT SHE HAS A FEW MONEY
AND GETS ROYALTY CHECKS EVERY
WEEK, A FAT DONATION TO MAKE
YOURSELF FEEL BETTER IS NO
PROBLEM.
KAUFMAN ADDS CASTING WASN'T A
CONSCIOUS DECISION BASED ON
THEIR RACE BUT ON THEIR
CHEMISTRY WHICH TRICKLE WITH
EACH OTHER.
WHICH IS WHY THE ROLE OF
CHANDLER DID NOT GO TO MR. T.
WOULD'VE BEEN A GREAT FEE BE.
PREVIOUSLY KAUFMAN'S COPRODUCER
DEFENDED THE CHOICES ADDING "I
WOULD'VE BEEN INSANE NOT TO HIRE
THOSE SIX ACTORS.
WHAT CAN I SAY?
I WISH LISA WAS BLACK?
WHO'S LISA?
ANYWAY, HE WILL BE WORKING IN
HOLLYWOOD AGAIN.
THE IDEA OF CASTING SHOWS BASED
ON RACE RARELY WORKS.
ISN'T THAT HOW WE GOT KAMALA?
BUT IT'S TRUE, IT WOULD BE NICE
TO HAVE MORE BLACK CHARACTERS ON
TV.
GOD, I LOVED THE COSBY SHOW.
SHOUT OUT TO AMERICA'S DAD.
JIM.
IT'S LIKE THE WHITE RACE IS THE
ONLY ONE THAT HAS THIS NEW
HEREDITY SIN.
LIKE WE'LL HAVE TO APOLOGIZE FOR
OUR PIGMENT.
>> Jim: I GUESS BLACK
CHARACTERS MATTER.
I DIDN'T KNOW.
I KNEW BLACK LIVES MATTER BUT NO
BLACK CHARACTERS MATTER.
LOOK, IF THEY ARE GOING TO BE
DOLING OUT MONEY LIKE YOU SHOWED
COSBY, WE SHOULD ALL GET MONEY.
THE CREATORS OF COSBY GOING
"THIS IS AMERICA'S DAD.
YOU TRICKED US.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
>> Jim: EVEN IF THEY ADDED
BLACK CHARACTERS, I WOULDN'T
HAVE WATCHED ONE EPISODE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> Greg: YOU ARE MORE OF A
SEINFELD GUY?
>> Jim: NEITHER.
FRIENDS, WHATEVER HAIRCUT THEY
HAD.
THEY WENT OUT AND GOT IT,
EVERYONE WENT OUT AND GOT IT.
IT WAS AWFUL.
>> Greg: I FORGOT.
WHENEVER JENNIFER ANISTON GOT A
HAIRCUT, EVERYBODY DID.
>> Jim: EVEN THE GUYS.
I AM LIKE CHANDLER.
WHO THIS BE 24 IS CHANDLER?
I DON'T WANT TO HANG OUT WITH
THE GUY WHO THINKS HE IS LIKE
CHANDLER.
>> Greg: I AM LIKE LOOKING
BEHIND THE SCENES AND SEEING
EVERYTHING ON THE SHELVES.